Do you know what I hate?
But 2 bags of Milano cookies, Mary?
You don't know me at all!
Exactly. Feelings.
Especially when they are irrational feelings, what for me
the whole goddamn time.
I get angry about nothing.
Look out your caps, you idiot!
I'm getting too quick.
Why do I have so many butter knives?
I don't even eat butter.
And often I have, without regrets
conflicting feelings.
I feel so harmonious with everything now, you know?
I now have such a respect for everything that lives.
And, I feel like I'm one with the universe.
My feelings tend to be very illogical,
to be intense and overwhelming.
And it's hard for me not to be swallowed up by them.
Before I started therapy and antidepressants,
I had no idea that this was abnormal.
I thought everyone had such intense feelings about it
everything and everyone, all the time.
And it was until I was diagnosed that I realized
that my feelings are fake news.
Mm ..
When I feel overwhelmed by emotions,
the best thing I've learned from my therapist to do,
is this breathing exercise where you inhale through
your nose for 4 seconds, you hold it for 4 seconds,
and then exhale through your mouth for 4 seconds.
It really helps when you are just overwhelmed by feelings.
and when to calm yourself down.
But the worst thing about my feelings is
that despite being extreme, it takes me a lot of time
to really process them.
And to figure out what is going on.
Because, more often than not, by the time I do
get overwhelmed by emotion, it is triggered
something small and the underlying problem is
something completely different that was ago or
and some other different things that happened that
I have not processed.
And once I know why I am one
feel certain, it is much easier to remedy.
I'm really sorry. I uhm ..
I have a lot of back and posture complaints at the moment.
And I take care of myself poorly so ..
it is entirely my fault.
The best advice I have for someone who
mood swings or just experiencing very intense emotions
is to forgive yourself
when you try to figure it out.
Because you can breathe until you drop, but sometimes
your feelings just get too much for you.
For example: I was recently on the phone with a friend
and we were shouting over and over again
something very innocent that he had said
until we both realized that we
had not had our day and our feelings had increased
and were reacting to each other.
So be patient with yourself
when you try to solve it.
They learn along the way.
and hopefully you do it better 50% or more of the cases.
I'm Anna Akana
Stay great Gotham.